si vous avez connu la deux chevaux alors
cette photo regardez vous rappellera
sans doute des souvenirs août 1963 à
tous les mythiques bouchons de la
nationalité une ambiance avec ses
voitures et gendarmes d'époque comme
resurgit du passé ce weekend à
Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine souvenirs avec
Aurélie Renaud
la route se fait à bord d'un J7 de 1977
et des bouchons ce véhicule en a vu
Isabelle se souvient des trajets de
vacances avec ses parents on disait
quand est-ce qu'on est rendu
dans pas longtemps répondait les parents
c'était pas toujours vrai en partant
très très tôt on espérait qu'on n'aurait
pas les bouchons mais forcément je
trouvais tous dedans puisqu'on partait
tous en même temps avant l'ouverture de
l'autoroute tout le monde emprunte la
nationale entre Paris et Bayonne et à
Sainte-Maure les bouchons se forment
régulièrement Pascal et Béatrice de La
Membrolle-sur-Choisille participe
régulièrement aux bouchon géant sur
l'attelage de leurs quatre chevaux tout
le nécessaire pour camper version 60 70
vous avez la machine à laver
la machine à laver la cocotte-minute à
la moulinette pour
pour la purée la purée des équipements
chinés en brocante qui replonge le
public dans de lointains et euux
souvenirs
de ça que ça permettait de laver le
linge et en même temps on pouvait s'en
servir comme baraque et tout on
transportait tout et le siège pliant
nous ça nous est arrivé plusieurs fois
si on le mettait mal pauvre on était par
terre les rideaux à motifs et la boîte
orange pour les œufs la pendule devenue
vintage et la pile électrique il y a
également le bikini la boîte à savon et
bien sûr à la fameuse glacière orange
Isabelle Chine et récupère tout ce que
les Français emmenaient en vacances une
immersion au camping version seventies
qui ravie les passants moi ce qui me
fait plaisir c'est qu'ils sont heureux
de revivre ce qu'ils ont vécu ou de
passer à leurs enfants aussi d'expliquer
que leurs grands-parents avaient ça
parce que bon ils ne sont plus là
aujourd'hui et nous on essaye de
retrouver tout ça à moindre coût pour
faire plaisir
quand vous venez nous voir le bouton
géant une eau de vacances et à la
nationale 10 désormais devenue mythique